dude I'm so pumped to have you this is
gonna be great three two one
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
today we're featuring Alexander green
what's up nice to be here thanks for
coming on the show man chorus thanks for
having me really appreciate it this is
totally the future of audio visual art
and experience CEO of symmetry labs for
years now yeah yeah yeah
maybe my the it's funny you know I think
Peter Thiel's said companies always have
a prehistory and made that my first
piece of art like six years ago now so
it seems arbitrary saying the company's
four years old but that's around when we
decided to quit our day jobs and do it
for real and you did some physics and
mathematics at University of Rochester
mhm and then you were like let me get
into the future of art and the future of
audio-visual experience so like how the
hell did that even happen it's kind of a
crazy story definitely was not a
straight line I always thought since I
was 11 I wanted to be a physicist I
remember the first time I read about
black holes and you know the fact that
you know Stephen Hawking got paid to
think about them all day and I thought
it was just so you know so amazing yeah
thinking about the universe and I love
math and I loved loved art and strangely
never really loved engineering
particularly I always liked you know I
was more of an ideas guy I guess and so
yeah I did I did a lot of physics and
math and did you know published 1:1
paper and realized academia was not
actually where I wanted to be and wanted
out to Silicon Valley and saw people
that were you know my age and starting
companies and just building their dreams
and saying it you know and doing it
and was really inspired by that oh yeah
you know it felt like you're growing up
in New York it was more of a culture of
like oh you pay your dues you know you
work your way up the ladder and that was
just never you know I'm just like to
anti-authoritarian and to rebellious
like
you really want to play that game nice
and it's good that you ended up kind of
landing out here seeing people kind of
it shipping their dreams and that
working really hard to do so and not
following academia which you actually
ended up fitting your personality and
your execution your vibe much better now
what you've built is just it's amazing i
I'm so in love with it
let's Ronnie can you throw up let's
throw up some of the symmetry labs work
we we have a bunch of great assets to
show you guys and the art is just and
this is like
Wow this TV shoot for Fox we're Jewish
to chandeliers cult sisters infrared
sensors and floor and look at how
massive that is compared to the size of
the people yeah it's really hard to
capture on video because scale is such
an important part of the work he's now
and just being immersed in it
[Music]
some commercial work to us for Nike
obviously
I was Super Bowl City San Francisco we
made this game where kids could pick
their favorite team and then they're
like if they bite fastest their team's
colors would win we love them for doing
you to include that exercise component
look at this this is an interactive
dance floor for a panoramic Music
Festival in New York such a great idea
yeah I was fun people loved it yeah we
don't actually do a lot of music
festival work even though people always
expect us to but this is you could live
program to that garden that was actually
at a Google event you could just right
light right the light patterns like
right on a computer next to it I'm
excited to talk about the tech as well
it's a lot of tacker so oh that's great
to have it right up over the orchestra
as well
it's like LED sex girl is dating once
described it as LED porn I wasn't sure
how I felt about that so okay so let's
let's take let's take a let's try and go
back to the beginning so we saw this
tree tree of 10 year 10 or a 10 or a as
far as I know it's an African word an
array and the tree of ténéré is was that
Burning Man in 2017 17 and this tree is
like 30 feet tall taller I was like
close to 40 not quite 40 feet tall also
probably that wide yeah about the same
diameter yeah and then it's what is it
like a million LEDs not quite there's
about 170,000 okay and 25,000 leaves so
Wow yeah so it's a lot of lot of
components each leaf had a circuit board
in it you know so each leaf has a
circuit board mm-hmm okay so let's let's
let's unpack these like a couple of
these at a time because it's just so
fascinating so you took do you make the
leaves and the tree of ténéré did you
make them would you make them out of the
actual molds for those the the leaves
themselves are TPU which is basically a
polyurethane like resin that's widely
used in various you know commercial and
consumer products the tree itself is
primarily made of like marine grade
steel a very heavyweight steel because
it was had to be stamped to support like
100 mile an hour winds and 60 climbers
which I was surprised was even possible
to get like an engineer to say sure have
60 people climb this tree but but you
know it was it just required a you know
absurdly thick steel the welders were
like you know we've never even worked
with this
you know and so that was challenging
yeah the the designing the leaves though
it was a lot of a lot of time was spent
figuring out how to do it and when we I
sort of had an aha moment after during
months of research on the truck trying
to figure out how to do these leaves
because it was just such a vicious
project doing that many LEDs distributed
you know across 25,000 leaves and doing
it all in six months and making sure it
worked and was you know cost-effective
and it ended up being you know like sort
of a dead simple design that the leaves
were injection balled in two halves and
then there was a flexible LED strip that
was bent around itself in general you
can't bend them like continuously but if
you bend them once you can get away with
it and sit that way the LEDs could shine
on both sides exactly yep and there'd be
like what like ten LEDs on one place
yeah close seven actually so they were
sort of like three pointing out each way
than one pointed out the center Center
yeah well so then that would just get
stuffed into the center of this leaf yep
and then that the halves would go on top
of it and then you would glue it in
silicon yeah I want to see this in more
place as I was just telling you before
the show that we have like the Bay
Bridge we have the art we have the LED
lights there we have this Exploratorium
we have this LED art there we are
starting to have more and more of it
across the world in different places
these immersive LED art audio-visual
experiences but so many of these are not
permanent which sucks
like where is the tree of ténéré right
now it's in Reno New York generator okay
the tree of ténéré is actually in Reno
out on a it's actually uncovered was
sort of rusting sadly but we've been
fortunate to get a couple more trees
commissioned by various people on the
world so we have one going in to Oslo it
was commissioned by a major art
collector there and it's being donated
to the city of Oslo's with permanently
gonna be installed in Oslo Stein Erik
Hagen it's really exciting thank
goodness yeah Oslo is doing there
right yeah I can't wait it's gonna be
amazing I mean also Oslo is dark half
the year obviously you know so it's a
really great place to do light on well
also half the year it's like yeah true
but and then we're also gonna be doing
one in Vegas Oh with a with a really
cool show called absinthe and really
great people it's sort of it's the best
show in Vegas right now it's like this
sort of hipster Cirque du Soleil with
with like very artsy you're right next
to the performers and so I'm really
excited to work with them and this is
gonna be a show that you make your
experience that comes along with the
show that they use on their set at the
show you know it's actually gonna be out
they have this French circus tent where
they hold the show in and it's gonna be
right outside there oh cool so it's just
gonna be an art piece but I normally
probably wouldn't have done something
and they guess if I didn't just cuz you
know Vegas is so sort of like flashbang
boom you know not you know you don't
associate it with art but I I went and
saw their show and I really liked Ross
who who started it and I really liked
the whole team that runs it and they're
just they're just full of like passion
and soul for what they do and that's why
it's like sold out every single night
you know it's the most popular show in
Vegas so there's a reason yeah and so
you have Oslo you have a tree that's
going up there that's so exciting a
permanent one
what other cuz we saw so many of these
other ones because we need to get it
there's so much to talk about
technicalities as well we saw all these
other exhibits that you guys made you
guys made the you guys have cubes you
like cubes a lot and those cubes are
probably a thinner steel or an aluminum
aluminum so they're an aluminum even
lighter and then you have the LEDs just
kind of rolling on the side so you can
see it from any side as well yep
so then the way that you know the way
that they're connected let's unpack this
one and then we'll keep unpacking
examples but the way that they're
connected then you can take
the so there has to be some electrical
engineering component as well okay I
need to distribute electricity to the
LEDs mm-hmm so the usually since there's
cubes stacked on top of each other you
can kind of hide the electrical wiring
as much as you can until the final which
will then go to usually a generator so
the cubes actually run power over
ethernet so it's one and that was a very
contrarian choice when we first designed
them but no one did this but still no
one does this for lighting fixtures
power over ethernet is primarily
designed with security cameras in mind
so you can you know pluck something that
has power and data but even you know I
think you know part of good engineering
is sort of hacking you know and we
realized that oh well we can get enough
power you know LEDs are fairly efficient
you know very efficient really yes and
so we can get just enough power over
power for Ethernet to power one cube so
it's one cable per cube and it goes in
at the back and it's an interchangeable
widely available cheap cable that's mass
produced rather than using some
proprietary cabling system which a lot
of like lighting products do and then
the cubes actually fold flat for
shipping great so so there's a there's a
every single part it's it's such a
simple idea you know so I thought like
oh let's make an LED cube you know that
and I wanted to make the modular so you
could make these different sculptures
out of them and it's sort of like the
the physical equivalent of a voxel you
know like rather than a pixel which is a
2d you know sort of the modular
component of 2d images cubes or a voxel
so which would bush would stand for
basically like volume pixels that's
right okay yeah so but you know like so
many things in life you know doing it is
a lot harder than thinking about it and
every single component on the cubes is
custom-designed it's it's there's
literally like 150 components on there
there's four hinges none of which is the
same because to make fix something fold
there's a sort of a symmetry baked into
it so it's like not like you know
they're complicated to assemble they're
complicated to make but that being said
the design at the end
give this sort of simple elegance you
know like a lot of good design does you
know with an iPhone or whatever you know
it's like look simple but it's not yes
yeah exactly we know nothing about the
black box we're trying to unpack a
little about it to understand it more
yeah I like how your symmetry lives but
you need a little bit of asymmetry oh
yeah yeah yeah and I like how you're
talking about when you were initially
thinking about making this volume pixel
that it was that you would need to
somehow make it so that it could like
fold down he could be we're really
thinking about transportation and
efficiency and setting it up quickly I'm
surprised you have one power over
ethernet cable per cube mm-hmm huh okay
so that means if you have like 100 cubes
you get a hundred mm-hmm a lot of cable
fun Ethernet cables yep damn that's a
lot of Ethernet cables it is and we
we've thought about doing some
proprietary solution with cabling that
would be you have less cables but you
ultimately need to get power to every
single one so you do you know you could
have a thicker cable that went to one
and then some sort of daisy chain
situation where you but you know and it
would be that would be a little bit
better but they'd be also be bulkier and
then be more costly and a good point
yeah we've found in general that that
even though it's definitely a lot of
cables it's it's a there's a lot of
things that are really good about the
solutions very simple it's very cost
effective and running cables doesn't
actually take that long you know so so
we had an explainer video which lets
let's throw up the explainer video and
we can keep on packing like the software
as well yeah
how are the artists who made that crazy
Burning Man tree this is a piece we made
in from New York City it was up all
winter we make lights go all six months
that's rockin six via pretty much from
yeah from December
you can walk on we submitted a
collaborative proposal to Burning Man
for this tree four stories tall seven
LEDs initially twenty-five thousand one
hundred and seventy-five thousand
seventies people climbed it we got a
full symphony in ballet under it people
got married under having so much fun the
reaction yeah I was it was a really
overwhelmingly positive reaction it was
great because everyone everyone loved it
not just you know exactly when he had
kids that love this NYC exhibit to make
less kids at Burning Man this is the
acrylic that made the domes there's two
halves yeah the middle yeah
a week to assemble 11 very sophisticated
sculptures that we have never built neat
thousand LEDs aside wiring is just
unbelievable we've ever built before its
culture yeah the way that we had to
build these because of the time crunch
was just so crazy
it was literally all LED strips rather
than sort of you know say a custom
shaped LED screen or something which
would have made more sense if we have
more time and we had to run this whole
AC system out into the street the mr.
ping who is an absolute genius of this
entire computer vision programming
program that we used military-grade IR
cameras up above overhead actually
thermal cameras technically they detect
the signature sculptures impressively
survived the wind survived two feet of
snow since social media seemed to really
heat it up
those two kids got it immediately two of
it we're like they're like you're like a
light J like it might be life he did
like as a secret yeah yeah a lot of
stuffs under NDA still exactly exactly
hopefully hopefully this is something
that we always love talking about but
hopefully we can do a better job at when
people create really good technology
into the world that it's not as so much
about quickly ripping people off but
rather like hey how do we reward the
people that actually made this and then
help spread it across the world so okay
so that is that what you when was that
that was how many months ago oh the sea
of light went up in December of 2017
okay so that just came down pretty much
recently
yeah that's so cool okay so so first of
all where was that in New York I was in
the Seaport so sound Street Seaport
yep it wasn't like the south east side
of Manhattan cool and then how did you
how does someone even land a deal like
that they're just like hey we want to
build something cool in our Seaport area
yeah that's good it's a good question
and I think that we've been really
fortunate that word-of-mouth and people
that just love our work follow us for a
while and then when they have budget for
it we'll reach out you know we had a
very we have a very like sort of hip
forward-thinking client there Howard
Hughes they're a real estate developer
mm-hmm and Steve Cornwell who's the CMO
there is just a very very sharp guy and
and he gets it he gets what well we know
what we're doing and and he knew people
would love it and and there's a good
synergy because really they just want to
make the Seaport a fun and engaging
place for people to go and so they
commissioned this piece of art I like
how you say they just get it because I
feel like I am starting to get it and
we're really excited to scale up our
events to massive sports stadiums and
when we get there we're going
meet some amazing our visual art and
experience so you know I'm n and we're
gonna crush it together we got to get
the right budget together to make it
wild you know as a wild is even more
wild we want to make your dreams come
true like you're like what's like I got
it I'll ask you that at the end but um
okay along the way so you said you know
ping you got a good team
like how many people are on this team we
have an incredible team the the
full-time we have about eight people and
then we're really fortunate to work with
incredible people like ping and Kyle
Fleming there's another just really
brilliant programmer that they
contribute you know regularly but aren't
don't just do this ping does a lot of
human rights work he's an actor right
now whoa yeah so you know we really yeah
we're really fortunate to you know be in
San Francisco and get to work with some
best people in the world it's all there
is to it yeah that is yeah some of those
it allows us obviously to make better
you know yeah there are you know the
technology really enables us to to do
things that are you know emotionally
powerful and beautiful yes and a lot of
times we have to invent technology which
we don't just invent things for the sake
of it you know it's more like we have an
experience we want to create and then
what do we need to do to get there yep
and often it turns out we have to do
some hard yeah it's good ok so you
got this team about eight full feet or
so full timers and so then you gave a
really interesting example when you were
doing this work in the Seaport that you
also set up cameras and this was
infrared or thermal or both their
thermal thermal thermal so in the
difference this was new to me by the way
it's sort of interesting thermal I mean
it's a type of infrared but it just it's
sensitive enough to pick up you know the
actual like heat that your body gives
off versus the cold ass New York Times
exactly exactly
with IR you generally have to like shoot
I are out and then like see what it
bounces off with thermal you can
reliably detect you know a person even
if they're wearing a jacket and you know
only their face is visible which we
actually did tests up and
good you know like yeah yeah so it's
it's pretty cool and so then the thermal
cameras were and this is brilliant
because the computer vision and the code
that was able to detect where they were
and then also send that signal to the
LED what did you call the little half
what was each one of those called oh oh
you know good I like that son so they
would send it to that son where the
person was walking by and then you would
add a flare to it well it's actually a
little it's close it's there's a layer
of abstraction in there that it was
missing and that's good so we have a
central piece of software everything we
do we have a full 3d model and that
sounds really obvious but but no one
does this and in addition to knowing
where things are we also know where the
pixels are and how they're serialized so
we can send the data appropriately so we
have one piece of software that runs
that whole installation has you know
there were 11 orbs in the in the
installation and when so these cameras
that are above one of the problems are
to solve is like the cameras and camera
space obviously don't know where the
people are in world coordinates they're
just detecting in camera space right so
you got to like you got to you know do
this sort of measurement technique where
you hold rulers out in front of the
camera you know in a square and so you
have to remand you have to write a
transformation which is looking
basically like a nonlinear matrix to get
from camera space into world space and
then once you're in world space law you
send that to the software the
coordinates of the person and where
they're moving and then the animation
which is running on the sculpture
responds to that you know the people's
velocity and position so depending on
their speed in the proximity correction
orb and then you had to do it there's a
map that you had to make yep of the yeah
that this is this is really cool yep
yeah this is way more complex than you
know virtually meets the highway yeah it
was surprising too because there are
things like there are sort of black box
solutions like Xbox Kinect or something
which work very well for tracking
somebody over a very small area yeah
like for like 5 feet 10 feet you know
they work great but that it doesn't work
at all
for me this is like you know 30 meters
by 20 meters or something yeah it's just
way bigger yeah and there's absolutely
no out-of-the-box solution that works we
tried all of them and you made your own
yeah we just rolled I love it and so now
all the all these different tech stacks
that you're making can also be licensed
actually yeah that could be a model for
for further sustainability and growth
which is that which is fantastic I'm
happy that we got a little bit into the
the technical nuance of the software and
computer vision and how that works with
the electrical engineering the
mechanical engineering I mean this is a
big this is not this is very difficult
to do yeah we're a hardware software and
art startup yeah art startup I love it
okay so you also did this I think this
was really interesting to highlight you
had these these these were thin
rectangles so that were lined up across
the art the floor the dance floor and
there oh yeah
and so this is also cool because I think
a lot of people have been in that space
so you we can envision ourselves right
now on it on a dance floor and right now
the like the coolest thing we have is we
have those you know when you're on a
dance floor and this is not at you know
Coachella or wherever but this is when
you're at just a normal like dance floor
dance club sure you got these lights
that kind of like you got those move
lights that are programmable movable
that just like shine like big huge light
onto the dance floor in different colors
but when you have them so close they're
hanging like right above you and they're
you know LED strips that are moving and
whizzing by and in different colors this
I think this adds a whole new vibe to
the floor and to the experience and also
that was I was an outdoor event right
yeah the had to figure out which one you
were talking about cuz we did an actual
LED dance floor that responded but this
portal this I was in
though it could be outdoors and this is
infrared you said yeah that Austria also
has infrared sensors but those the
infrared sensors here are in the floor
yep every 18 inches or so and that's
it's all walk a little slower for it to
catch up yeah I would like it if they
were if there were more of them but yeah
you know Gentoo but it works very
reliably that's it's a lot easier
actually from a software perspective cuz
there's a lot of just individual sensors
and they're either detect something or
they don't and then this was a this was
an LED screen or what was the it's
basically an LED screen that you can
drive on no I it's like it can take a
lot of weight and and it has infrared
sensors every yeah you know I think it's
actually ever six inches so this
combined with what I was talking that
would be really cool have you guys we
haven't we'd be so freakin crazy for it
I'd love to do like a dance club of the
future that's definitely on the list oh
that's on the list you have a big list
exact tell us about oh oh man okay now
this came up maybe we should talk about
this quick sure yeah so we're designing
some we've been thinking about the
future of public spaces and and you know
the intersection of sort of lighting and
an ambient information display not you
know really sort of the intersection I
guess a functional lighting design and
art you know and so this is one concept
that we're working on for a major real
estate developer in for a project in
Florida but I don't know if I can talk
about yet exactly but pretty excited
we're gonna do a series of sort of
street lamps from the future that are
programmable I love that I mean this
right now we have these whatever it is
Jesus these steel beams jutting from the
sidewalk and then I freakin jut out into
the street and then there's these little
like three circle like lamps that it's
just it's funny because they've been in
place for so long and they just do the
job and the ideas that like do the job
most efficiently but how do you do the
job in more futuristic way
and make it also more this ambient
information communication as well so so
now you're doing red light green light
yellow light and then you can do cool
things like weather or transit data and
like all this cool stuff that exactly
yeah we've been talking about that in
the BART corridor for a while that
Market Street people are like oh let's
make the different colored lines and
have them show up in LED so you know
when the train is coming and you can go
down there there's been all this no
totally I think there's a lot of things
that could get communicated through
light that would be less intrusive than
a notification on your phone or like a
you know some sort of announcement on a
loudspeaker you know and I think that
would be hopefully that's sort of part
of the future of public spaces I think
it is because I think that the the world
sort of like devolve Accords this like
assault on your senses you know and I
think it'd be really nice if we could
figure out a way to have you know our
sort of public spaces and shared spaces
be alive and communicate the necessary
information but in a way that's more in
harmony with our you know just our
senses you know yeah sort of flow state
yep with our senses and also with
there's our 15-minute timer thank you
Ron and also with ecology may be true
yeah I'm guys been considering like
adding I mean you obviously did a
digital tree but have you also
considered doing like adding in vines
and actual plants into the mix yeah I'd
love to do more stuff with plants I love
plants some plants and LEDs as well
actually what originally got me super
interested in in LEDs funny enough was I
am somewhat of an expert on hydroponics
and I used to grow we medical well
before was recreational I used to go
prep medical cannabis yeah
LEDs we're not quite good enough then to
do high-intensity plant growth they were
just getting there
she was canned and I was like doing a
lot of research on to them and realizing
that when you could if you could program
LEDs to be on just when there's a lot of
wasted light and heat from high pressure
sodium and metal halide bulbs which is
true
only what's been used to grow plants
indoors mm-hmm and also plants can't
their metabolisms don't work they can't
they need 12 hours of light to get their
signaling so they know it's time to like
flower but they they waste a lot of that
so there's actually LEDs I think are
definitely the future of horticulture as
well and and yeah agriculture even so I
think there's a lot a lot to be done
with programmable lighting across a lot
of different industries I like is how
you make that tie to how LEDs can
actually help so much with agriculture
as well yeah they can I mean it's just
it's definitely a pretty incredible
technology and it's it's funny because
it's not you know brand spanking new
it's not the thing that everyone's
talking about like with you know AI or
machine learning or something which we
also do some of but but you know yeah
they're there their time I think is
still really just coming into existence
in a way so I wonder tomorrow when we
host David Rosenberg from arrow farms I
wonder if from vertical farming Oh
colder I wonder how much LED I bet he'll
have some interesting things to say
about it that's good
see how it all connects you know yeah
it's so interesting this is why the
multidisciplinary approach to life is so
fascinating absolutely and that's what
you know a lot of our vibes are you know
you or you dabbled in so much and that
kind of coalesced into this and now so
now let's ask you about your vision
because we kind of touched on this in
the beginning and I wanted to ask you
what is on this list of epic projects
that you want to build out well I'd like
to do more large public art pieces I
really like doing stuff in public I love
seeing how permanent ones
yeah permanent work yeah permanent
permanent or semi-permanent
I definitely mmm we did a lot we did a
lot of events we've largely bootstrapped
doing corporate events you know like he
did and that just burned me out on like
one one two three day events a bit
because we do there was just so we did
so much work on such tight timelines and
I think we're really glad that we sort
of graduated from that but that being
said I'm definitely open to you know
semi-permanent pieces like the sea of
light which was up for five months was
wonderful but yeah I want to do more
permanent
and and keep doing some more keep doing
more large-scale works I love just
seeing people's reactions to it and
seeing people inspired by it I mean this
the Seaport was freezing cold it was
like zero degrees plus tons of windchill
and on a Saturday thousands of people
would come out a lot of families would
come out from New Jersey or from Staten
Island just to see it so you know and it
was it was you know inspiring for them
exactly to test them into creativity
yeah and so I'm excited about that
and that being said we also are doing
some designs for major concert like
major touring artists I was like I would
love to work with you know some of my
favorite artists like Radiohead or
something yeah do and I know their
lighting designer
Andy Watson so we've been talking I
would love to open more I'm considering
hoping sort of like gallery like or
museum like experience but a lot of
different pieces in it that that rather
doing the traditional sort of museum
gallery route just like circa mething
the whole thing and having our own
experience but we could just show off
what because I think that there is
something really important here and
telling the story of modern technology
through art because it can make real
reify if you will all of these fairly
abstract things you know like in a
powerful way and tell the story of now
you know and what's possible you know
we're always we're literally always
pushing what's possible and and
benefiting from the open source
community you know and think you know
tools released by you know Facebook's AI
team and google's AI and computer vision
and and all and and it's such an
exciting time to be working with with
technology and leveraging it for art and
I just want to keep keep doing that so
yeah and then also it you know to the
streetlamps I'm really excited about
doing some more functional lighting and
being a part of the future of buildings
and being part of the future of cities
yes like on some level we're just doing
software-controlled
you know things are software controlled
lighting and you know I think we might
be able to win that so yeah and you know
the future of buildings is what is gonna
be on the
a building yeah how is information gonna
be communicated rather than just the
brick or young whatever it is now and
Windows now we can have completely
different information communicated from
the sides of buildings I'm really happy
that you listed by having a an
audio-visual experience Museum because I
think that is an amazing idea that needs
to happen there's already so many
successful like there's that ice cream
museum there's all these things that are
that are like experience oriented design
and yeah if I totally think in a one
based on symmetry labs is work across
different kind of nodes that you can
walk through and experience different
one I think that's a really good idea
and you can even move out the exhibits
and maybe turn those into public after a
cycle of six months or whatever put them
in places like Oslo because they
actually know spent more than the US
does at times about I wish that the US
could pick up on some cues like that and
start implementing faster San Francisco
has done a decent job New York just did
obviously but we're not good enough
there's so many of this that could that
could just be incredible additions to
the city even if they're semi-permanent
for six months yeah throw it in there
see what happens see how much attraction
it gets you know are there people that
want it there are there people that
don't want it there permanently why
let's have these conversations I'm
excited for your vision very excited for
it and I really want to build something
cool together so hopefully we can work
on a really cool piece just I'm sure
we'll collaborate on something I'm sure
yeah we there's there's so many people
that love what you're doing and that
will will unplug in hopefully that will
help you guys have all the creative
juices brought into the world okay Alex
let's ask you a couple questions that we
like asking on the show all right I
think this first question is an
important one for you because you
probably have an opinion on it the world
is moving more into like a global eye
state
and we have this exponential
technologies kind of exacerbating like
how quickly the 1% is like skyrocketing
and the bottom like socio-economic class
is like slowly climbing up what do you
think is gonna happen with that gap whew
that's a very good question and a very
tough one to answer I think that what's
gonna happen is going to depend on what
we do as a society I think that we're
gonna either end up with I think to
avert some sort of very bad consequence
like some you know violent revolution
you know the sort of civilization you
know falling apart we're going to have
to do we're gonna have to come up with
some sort of new economic system and I
hesitate to suggest which one because I
think that needs to be left to people
that just think about these things but I
read a lot about you know universal
basic income and a lot of different
approaches to to doing this and I think
you know I think that the good news is
that I'm seeing more and more people
talk about this openly and I'm glad it's
not verboten you know that and that it's
not just people on the bottom or at the
top that if it feels to me like it's
becoming more of a mainstream societal
issue to discuss you know income
inequality and wealth inequality and
what's gonna happen yeah you know
hopefully we won't do anything stupid
and heavy-handed because the you know
free markets and capitalism have gotten
us you know really far they've gone but
that being said there's also major
structural problems with them you know
like externalities and I think that sort
of Randy and libertarianism misses a lot
of major flaws in capitalism as well so
hopefully we can figure out something
that is a hybrid of the you know best
ideas you know that we have yeah there
needs to be an augmentation to the
economic fabric yeah yeah and we're just
too rapidly moving into the space of
exponential technologies yep yeah and we
need to figure it out so bad yeah it was
this
yeah and it's not just that one right
exponential technology is also
exponential risk you know if you get you
know when you have like synthetic
biology and like gene editing and and
make it really easy to create you know
either
viruses that don't exist at all or old
ones that are have been eradicated you
know in your garage I mean that's a you
know it's becoming more and more real
risk by the day so we there is this
fundamental sort of mathematical problem
with with technology which is that it
gives people more power and that's
generally a good thing but it also
eventually gives smaller small groups
more power to do more damage and so you
know to be totally Frank I've thought
about this a lot and I feel like as far
as explanations for the you know the the
Fermi paradox or why there's not more
intelligent life out there well first of
all there may be and we just don't know
it but but this might be one of the
reasons we asked on the show is are we
alone in the cosmos yeah and it sounds
like you've thought about how
civilizations struggle with figuring out
how to work together on the rock
orbiting the star yeah yeah well I
definitely don't think I think that I
personally feel it's around like they
were alone and and that all of the
astronomical learnings from the last ten
years have been every single time I mean
like we keep updating towards oh wow
there's got to be a lot of life out
there but there's tons of water we found
lots of comments with like like complex
organic molecules
you know we're tons of habitable planets
in the sort of you know Goldilocks zone
around you know medium sized stars I
mean all that stuff was just not not
even known like 30 or 50 years ago or
even you know more recently
20 years ago we didn't know whether
water was plentiful or what you know and
it is and so you it's just it's really
tough for me to believe that we're along
the cosmos and but I just want to also
clarify on your thought you did you do
think that civilizations struggle with
figuring out how to work together that's
part of the far Fermi paradox yeah well
yeah I think that's I think it's very
likely seems to me to be very like you I
think it's hard to say anything
conclusively about this frankly just yes
we don't have I think it's a
civilization that you know I think one
but but we do have we have think about
how hard it is here yes and frequently
on earth you know or at least in human
civilization it's it's happened across
civilizations right we've had collapse
you know in everywhere from you know the
Mayans to you know many civilizations
across time I need to pull a Ron quote
for this one the earth is littered with
lost civilizations exactly yes yeah and
uh we're next
[Laughter]
I'm glad we can laugh at that but if we
don't get our together I mean
that's it just seems it that's what
happens yeah yeah if you don't get your
together that's what happens all
right let's ask you two more what do you
think we're in a simulation no using
this base reality well we are absolutely
absolutely a hundred percent not in any
simulation by any kind of computer that
we can imagine right now no way but the
complexity of so might be something
super complex that we can't imagine so
at some level you know but so I've
thought about this a lot too at some
level if it's a simulation made by a 10
dimensional computer that we can't
understand is it a simulation or is it
just running the program you know like I
guess it reminds me of what Buzz Aldrin
I think said when it was asked about the
moon conspiracy and he's like he's like
it would have been easier to just go
there than to fake it you know and so
I've actually done a lot of
computational physics simulations and I
mean even just computing like 10
gravitational bodies to figure out
what's gonna happen could take you know
like days on a supercomputer computing
one protein folding could take like tilt
the heat death of the universe you know
if you did it from first principles we
always use approximations whenever we
compute complicated things
so imagine the energy that is being used
to run what you're describing exactly I
guess my point is like I certainly think
that all the possibly think there there
are algorithms that
control reality you know I think like
you know physics is in a way physical
laws I think are probably approximations
to like algorithms you know in a way
that you know the and there is even some
some evidence at really large scales
galactic scales that physical laws and
constants may change over time
which sort of would would suggest that
so I think if it it may it may be that
there is some truth to the idea that
we're in a computer you know some sort
of computer simulation in the sense that
we're in a program yeah but but but but
I don't know that I would call it a
simulation in the sense that you know I
don't know that another yeah anything's
possible you know program and simulation
are kind of interchangeable in this
context I would say and I think the
energy required can be really figured
out through physics through fusion or
through starheart
energy obviously there's so many
different ways okay we can unpack that
one for a long time and I I'm happy that
you're also thinking about how the
variables are working in the program
because there are definitely some crazy
variables happening and there's some
crazy code baked into reality it's very
interesting to try and parse them and
and understand the rules of and yeah
what do you thinks the most beautiful
thing in the world
I think the most beautiful thing in the
world is collaboration true like true
work you know organizations working
towards a goal that's bigger than any of
us hell yeah
there's something so amazing about
getting a village of people together to
work on something that's bigger than the
village that impacts the rest of
humanity this trajectory through time I
love that so much I'm glad you said that
it's a good one
tell us a little bit more about like why
you think that well I mean I've never
asked that question before so I don't
know if I'm gonna stand by it but I I
think that I know that in my life I mean
there's some so many you know beautiful
things it's hard to say anyone because I
think many of the most beautiful things
I've ever experienced actually
ironically are also the product of one
mind you know like a you know Debussy
piano suite or like a Bach violin
concerto or you know general relativity
yeah pretty much every every singer
every did you know yes yes Toshi's works
very beautiful and so but even those
things ironically are collaborative
because they rely upon this this
incredible you know Canon of human
knowledge and it's like the old sort of
Galileo quote if it's I've seen further
than others it's because I stand on the
shoulders of you know yeah so so they're
really you know even though it's true
that they're the product of one line
that they still deeply collaborative you
know and and I've also just myself so
some of the most beautiful experiences
I've ever had have been frankly
something of some of these crazy art
projects but where it just it sort of
takes a village you know and and so many
incredibly brilliant people came
together to make them happen yes and and
contributed so much sometimes you know
sometimes it was a programmer that was
traveling around you know France never
even committed to github and showed up
at Burning Man with like
this amazing code you know sometimes it
was you know it's somebody just has a
day job working 8 hours a day
you know from 5 p.m. to 3 a.m. on an art
project just to help was like an
incredible mechanical engineer you know
I mean it's Wow and so seeing these big
teams rally to to do this has been you
know it's just very it's just very
beautiful because you know we you know
we live in such a individualistic
society I think so it's nice to see self
sacrifice for the for a greater vision
if I see further than others it's
because I stand on the shoulders of
giants I love it Alex screen what a
freaking pleasure yeah great thanks for
so much time trapping me on this has
been so mined enriching
I'm just we love your work we hope that
other people have taken what you're
doing and you've been inspired by it and
definitely get more involved in art in
especially audio visual art and
experience design like check this stuff
out
let's get art let's get civilization
more immersed in it because it's just
fun you can get it on the dance floor
you can get it at the public exhibits
for kids to get inspired by there's so
many different uses for this and it's
it's very inspirational so thanks
everyone for tuning in if you guys had a
good time definitely subscribe join the
family get the conversation rolling talk
to two people about what you learned
today have them go talk to two people go
and make something with this make a
video write about it go and create with
this knowledge don't just consume it
also join us on patreon you continue
supporting the studio growing this
enterprise continuing to impact more
people let's do it together go and
follow symmetry labs there links in the
bio as well alright everyone
much love thanks for tuning in
[Music]
you